comment faire quand une rumeur s'attaque
à vous parfois elles sont folles on a vu
dernièrement tout simplement gérard
jugnot sur les autres twitter qui est
mort c'était juste hallucinant montant
des grosses têtes il est dit qu'il était
vivant soit partiellement on l'a vu on
avait compris rachel vous il y en a une
et pas très très longtemps sur où il
n'ya pas très longtemps voilà bah j'en
ai entendu beaucoup si l'on est partout
partout rachel de grains et voilà mais
ce qui est bien et ce qui est dingue
c'est que sa part juste du fait qu' on
s'étonne flow d'instagram c'est énorme
oui je sais mais je dis oui en fait
voilà saint-valentin ensemble une folle
c'est plus une rumeur oui je sais mais
en fait on reste des gens normaux entre
guillemets on est fâché du coup bah
voilà et ça a pris des proportions assez
dramatique c'est que bas toute ma
famille est au courant avant même que
j'aie pu en parler à qui que ce soit
ouais j'ai pris cette décision ça se
doit la semaine dernière donc c'est
encore et vous avez que j'étais quand
même assez chic dans les mieux servis
mais a pâti si on rigole c'est beaucoup
du second degré mais voilà c'est ma vie
en fait je sais très bien que trois mois
pas faciles
voilà mais voilà c'est la vie on n'était
plus sur la même longueur d'ondés il est
encore très jeune et je pense qu'il a
besoin d'eux était très visitée belt a
la vie devant toi et toi quelque chose
j'adorerais avoir un chagrin d'amour
ça voudrait dire que j'ai un amour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
laniel n'en fait pas des n'en faites pas
trop sur sur les rumeurs voilà les
rumeurs qui s'attaque à vous c'est quand
même juste assez hallucinant il y en a
eu plein des rumeurs donc on va parler
aussi à l'udc
l'udc notamment oui oui oui bonjour le
matin et de l'hormone je crois que
chacun ici a aussi quelques rumeur un
peu folle qui sont sortis il ya des
rumeurs qui sont assez dingue qui dure
toujours c'était vous en précharge ir
dans les années 80 après pretty woman
il ya une rumeur qui perdure qui dit
qu'il avait été en urgence à los angeles
au cedars sinaï pour lui enlever une
gerbille were hamster alors là je vis ça
comme une souris hamster voilà comme ça
la gorge
non non non du des fesses du rectum et
l'orlistat sap tibet comme on sait qu'il
est qu'il est même utilisé la donne
était dans un préservatif
eh bien il faisait des petits jeux
amoureux vous devez connaître enfin
coûte elle est loin de la misère dans le
bain non par un tour des rumeurs
évidemment série singer nous regarde lui
obligé d'en parler souvent parce que les
gens ne reparle depuis trente bien sûr
d'alors aleris terre et tout imbibé le
petit le prince harry est un vrai pas
qui m'a dit ça ici autour de la table
c'est catherine le prince harry ne
serait pas le fils de charles ça je
pense que guillaume guillaume frisquette
en train de saigner du nez